look I know you know a lot about AI
right and you know how dangerous it is
potentially to humanity and what
opportunity is it also
um you know offers
but
it could kill us all I mean Elon said
first is going to steal our job then
it's going to kill us right yeah and
it's it's probably not hyperbole it's
actually you know if it follows the loss
of biological evolution which are just
the laws of mathematics that's probably
a good end point for it you know a a
potential endpoint
so
um we we need it's gonna happen but we
need to make sure it's regulated and
it's regulated properly for safety
in every country and and that includes
Russia and China and Iran
right now we we should be putting all
the weapons of war aside and sitting
down with us guys and say how are we
doing how are we going to do this
there's much more important things to do
we're gonna this stuff is gonna kill us
if we don't figure out how to regulate
it
and and Leadership needs to look down
the road at what what is the real risk
here and the real risk is that you know
AI will well you know enslave us for one
thing
and you know and and then destroy us and
do all this other stuff and how about
biological weapons
we're now all working on these
biological weapons and we're doing
biological weapons from
Ebola and um and you know Dengue fever
and you know all of these other bad uh
things and we're making ethnic by
weapons bio weapons that can only kill
Russians
the Chinese are making that you know are
can kill people who don't who don't have
Chinese genes
so all of this isn't out within reach
we're actively doing it
and we need to stop it and we can easily
a biological weapons treaty is the
easiest thing in the world to do
we can verify it we can enforce it and
everybody wants to agree to it it only
insane people do not want about want to
continue this kind of research there's
no reason to do it so there's these
existential threats to all of humanity
now out there like AI biological weapons
we need to start stop fighting each
other
start competing on economic game fields
Playing Fields instead of military
playing fields
which will be good for all of humanity
and that we need to sit down with each
other
and negotiate reasonable treaties on how
we regulate Ai and biological weapons
and nobody's talking about this in this
political race right now nobody's
talking about it in a government
they get fixated on these little Wars
and you know and uh these comic book
depictions of good versus evil and you
know and we all go you know uh and and
go off to and give them the weapons and
enrich
you know the military and complex but
we're we're on the Road to Perdition if
we don't end this and some of this
requires to have this kind of
phone that connects Khrushchev and John
F Kennedy that cuts through all the
bureaucracy to have this communication
between heads of state and in the in the
case of AI perhaps heads of tech
companies where you can just pick up the
phone and have a conversation because a
lot of it a lot of the existential
threats of artificial intelligence
perhaps even bio weapons is
unintentional it's not even uh strategic
it's actual effects so you have to be
transparent and honest about especially
with AI that people might not know
what what's the worst that's going to
happen once you release it out into the
wild and you have to have an honest kind
of communication about how to do it so
that companies are not terrified of
Regulation
uh overreach regulation and then
government is not terrified of tech
companies of uh manipulating them in
some director and direct ways so like
there's a trust that builds versus a
distrust
that that seems to so basically that old
phone or khushev can call John F Kennedy
is needed
yeah and you know I don't think there's
listen I don't understand AI okay I do
know I I can see from all this
technology how
it's this kind of turn keto
totalitarianism that once you put these
systems in place you know they can be
misused to enslave people and they can
be misused in wars and you know to
subjugate the kill to do all of these
bad things
and I don't think there's anybody on
Capitol Hill who understands this you
know we need to bring in the tech
community and say tell us what these
regulations need to look like you know
so that there can be freedom to innovate
so that we can
milk AI for all of the good things but
not you know fall into these traps that
are gonna you know that that are these
existential threats to that pose
existential threats to humanity